[Musique]
des gens qui ont installé les usines
dans leur maison dans des maisons
fermées
donc tu peux même pas savoir ça c'est
les voisins seulement qui savent que on
fabrique de l'eau là-bas des fois même
quand les autorités viennent pour
demander on leur dit pas on dit que non
il y a pas
[Musique]
usine ceux qui ont déjà leur
autorisation de fabrication bon il y a
pas de problème on les laisse continuer
mais les nouveaux ne peuvent plus avoir
de nouvelles autorisation de fabrication
en tout cas à
[Musique]
plas
ce microplastique peut-être ingurjeté
par les animaux erant ou les même les
ovins les beauins qu'on trouve dans la
nature les poissons également et on
s'est rendu compte depuis quelqu temps
dans nos assiettes on mangé du
microplastique venant du poisson venant
de la viande et cetera donc finalement
ce qui est é un défi environnemental
c'est devenu un défi
[Musique]
sanitaire